la presse à travers le monde en
compagnie de bonjour Hélène
les réactions la déclaration d'Emmanuel
Macron sur les non vacciné on a beaucoup
parlé hier que le président a dit avoir
très envie d'emmerder le site
les propos du chef de l'État déclencher
en tout cas des réactions en cascade
petite phrase grosse polémique titre Le
Parisien qui évoque une stratégie à haut
risque pour polarisé l'attention une
stratégie pour réactiver le Macron de
2017 le Macron disruptif animés par une
volonté de transgresser de bousculer de
ne pas céder à une forme de conformisme
comme il se décrire lui-même notre
l'opinion ou dessins de caca qu'on le
voit le montre des tournants la tirade
de Jean-Paul Belmondo dans le film à
bout de souffle si vous n'êtes pas
vacciné en ville si vous n'êtes pas avec
signer à la montagne si vous n'êtes pas
vacciné à la mer aller vous faire
évidemment à droite à gauche
français la peur la fatigue et
l'impatience provoquée par 2 ans de
covit vide Emmanuel Macron exemple de
pas seulement son gouvernement de tous
ces moments qui a commencé par l'absence
de véritables politique de l'hôpital il
installe volontairement dans l'espoir
d'en tirer un profit politique le
malsain et nous que l'on reproche au
populisme dénonce le figaro même son de
cloche du côté de libération vulgaire
vindicatif plutôt qu'en président de
rassemblement Emmanuel Macron se
présente en candidat du clivage en vue
de la présidentielle je sais comme elle
liberté viens mener c'est celle des
autres je deviens ami responsable et
responsable n'est plus un citoyen aussi
accès né le président au sujet des noms
vacciné des proposed indigne d'après
l'humanité qui voilà une manœuvre plein
de cynisme donc on peut Redoute et les
conséquences dans le dessin de coco pour
Libération le président sans poils
d'ailleurs à modifier la Déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen de 1789
du citoyen vacciné selon le président
prenez ça de con de non vacciné
dans l'ensemble la presse étrangère
c'est très bien ce qu'il fait plusieurs
insultes en
Arabie Saoudite le véhicule
avant le départ
en relation avec une entreprise
terroriste
tu n'as pas été revendiqué son mode
opératoire apparaître rudimentaire
d'après le Figaro le journal de
l'hypothèse que ça puisse être le
résultat d'une opposition
sur
un événement à
l'Exposition Universelle de
2019 lui finalement disputera peut-être
au tournoi de Melbourne
en
[Musique]
Australie
rester bloqué plusieurs heures à
l'aéroport de Melbourne une débâcle à la
Une de la presse australienne d'onde qui
est remise depuis hier sur la joke
Djokovic Djokovic les déboires du numéro
1 mondial fond derrière la Une de
plusieurs que tu viens à travers le
monde ce matin
refoulé le journal britannique les
rappels le refus du joueur de se faire
vacciner une attitude qui a scandalisé
l'opinion un dans un pays qui a connu
l'un des plus longs confinement au monde
près de 260 jours à haute dehors titre
l'équipe enfin pas tout à fait encore
puisque Novak Djokovic
rendre justice contre la décision des
autorités australienne qui sera examinée
des ce matin match plein de suspense
décidément on suivra merci beaucoup
Hélène merci à vous d'avoir choisi
FRANCE 24 en se retrouve dans un quart
d'heure pour un nouveau journal à tout à
l'heure
[Musique]